[Music and laughter]
This is amazing, you get this pulsating of
the reaction.
My name is Steve Mould,
I've got my own YouTube channel where I make
science videos.
Some of them are dangerous and if they are
then I assess the risks.
It's an important part of my job.
But sometimes you find out the hard way that
there are risks you didn't know about.
For example I was burning some aluminium powder
for a project
and I wanted the fire to go out.
So I poured water onto it which you should
never do.
So I made it my mission to figure out why
that's problem,
why you can't put out a metal fire with a
water fire extinguisher.
You can't put out a metal fire with a carbon
dioxide fire extinguisher either
which is really counter intuitive.
So that's what this video is about.
We're going to use magnesium instead of aluminium.
It's a little easier to set light to.
This is magnesium turnings.
I'm going to spread it out a little bit.
[Wooshing sound]
Alright.
And let's see if we can put it out.
It will not go out with a carbon dioxide fire
extinguisher.
If anything, it makes it worse.
The next thing is to try a water fire extinguisher.
This is really dangerous so we're going to
go up onto the roof of the Ri.
We're going to use a squeezy bottle instead
of an actual water fire extinguisher
just because I've got a bit more control over
this.
Just going to let it get going.
That's crazy bright, isn't it? Alright.
[Laughter]
So with a water fire extinguisher it's even
worse. It's explosive.
It's a bit like fireworks.
So why can't you put out a metal fire
with standard fire extinguishers like water
and carbon dioxide?
To figure it out, let's do it again in a more
controlled environment.
So I'm going to fill this beaker with gas
carbon dioxide.
To do that I've got solid carbon dioxide in
the bottom, dry ice,
if I add some water, it should start to fill
with carbon dioxide,
and you can actually see that happening there.
And let's try and put out a normal fire with
the carbon dioxide.
So I've got a piece of wood here.
We're going to set fire to it.
The wood is reacting with oxygen in the air.
That's the chemical reaction of burning.
It's the carbon in the wood.
And you also need heat as well. It's the fire
triangle, right?
Fuel, heat and oxygen.
So what happens when I dip this into the carbon
dioxide?
It goes out straight away.
That's because we're removing one of those things
from the fire triangle.
We're removing oxygen. So the chemical reaction
has to stop.
But let's try it again with magnesium.
It doesn't go out until it's all burnt.
So carbon dioxide can put out a wood fire
for the reasons you already know.
But it can't put out a metal fire.
But actually when you think about it, it's
weird that carbon dioxide,
it's weird that this can put out a wood fire.
Because if you think about it,
the explanation is that carbon dioxide starves
the fire of oxygen.
Except that carbon dioxide has oxygen in it.
It has two oxygens for every carbon.
In that really hot environment of a fire,
this carbon dioxide molecule is unstable.
The oxygen can be removed and the oxygen will
preferentially stick to
or react with the atom that pulls on it more
strongly.
And in the case of a metal fire it's the metal
atoms that win
and you're left with carbon that is stripped
of its oxygen.
Whereas with the wood fire you've got oxygen
that's either going to
bond with the carbon in the wood
or it's going to stick with the carbon in
the carbon dioxide.
There's no difference between the two, it's
a tug of war between carbon and carbon.
Nothing is going to happen.
The case with water, it's the same thing happening.
The reason using water is even worse is that
water can boil explosively,
taking bits of fuel with it and spreading
it around.
And the other thing is, when you strip oxygen
away from H2O, from water,
you're just left with hydrogen and hydrogen
gas is also explosive.
So don't use carbon dioxide or water on a
metal fire.
It's a class D fire so you have to use powder
which basically is -
you drop a solid mass over the fire and that
smothers the fire.
One final cool thing is that you can burn
magnesium
inside a block of solid carbon dioxide, otherwise
known as dry ice.
So we're going to give that a whirl.
We've created a little dip inside the block
of carbon dioxide here.
We're going to fill that with some some magnesium.
So the heat from the fire is turning the solid
carbon dioxide
into gaseous carbon dioxide. It's sublimation.
It goes straight from a solid to a gas.
And then it's getting so hot
that the magnesium can steal oxygen away from
the carbon dioxide
to form magnesium oxide. This is amazing.
You get this pulsating of the reaction. It
glows and dies down and glows again.
That's because the oxygen is being used up,
and then more of it is becoming available.
And I think now we're reaching the end
as that white light turns into more of an
orange glow.
Just black body radiation because it's still
hot in there.
Wow.
So there you go, more videos like that over
on my channel.
I recommend you start with a video about chladni
figures.
Link in the description.
And as always, don't forget to subscribe to
the Ri channel as well.
Both channels are on Patreon so you can support
us that way too.